next we have Natalie Millman
okay all right Canyon everyone hear me
all right good morning everyone Thank
You Mariana for a wonderful presentation
that was really a good way to start the
day broadening our horizons so thanks so
moving on there was a movie that came
out in December anyone know what I'm
talking about the one where and half
away when an Oscar for who tears Yallah
moods you know what I'm talking about
what a great movie of course it's kinda
bi-directionally relevant to us as
social workers too I mean we are aware
of the catch-22 that is life post
incarceration either stay in prison and
get treated inhumanely or great other
option you leave prison and get treated
inhumanely wow so it's a damned if I do
damned if I don't cycle I mean no wonder
people have difficulty getting out of a
cycle of desperation poverty substance
abuse and crime they're disempowered by
those with privilege and you know what
we as social workers can't do everything
that we want to do we can't do what the
priests dozen limb is we can't give our
entire collection of silver to every
person who needs it so that they can
start a new life we only have so many
silver candlesticks to give but of
course we can't be like the policeman
javert either aligning our egos to
systems that don't care about us or
about our clients not only can debt
leech disaster as it does for the poor
policemen in the story um but but I
don't think any of us wants to be a job
fair figure privileged people employed
with a job of chasing down less
privileged people engaging in massive
power struggles focused on trying to get
all the i's dotted and t's crossed but
wait a minute isn't that what we spend a
lot of our time doing anyway trying to
get all the i's dotted the t's crossed
oops so that leads to the question how
can we work for these frustrating
disempowering systems that seem like
they want to squeeze out every drop of
compassion and love that we want to
share with our clients and extinguish
the interface that motivates us because
as I'm sure many of you know it's a
reciprocal
relationship agencies that treat their
staff will treat their clients well too
and vice versa when those things don't
go together it keeps us from advancing
the greater good I'm clearly very
nervous I wish I could say that things
were different but unfortunately from
what I hear many agencies don't treat
their staff well and this impacts the
quality of the services provided to
clients when power is unequal the
privileged few gain more control and
those who lack privilege are
disenfranchised many of these systems
crush our clients telling them that they
don't have souls and you know what even
though many of us are privileged to beat
years in these systems we are often told
the same thing we don't have power so
we're faced with the question how can we
as social workers engage encourage our
clients to win back power for themselves
and at the same time how can we win back
power for ourselves too I don't have a
definitive answer to these questions but
I have a couple of ideas if I can turn
my page my idea is that we can approach
our clients from the perspective of
personal history now what does it mean
to be practicing personal history or
being a personal historian in a nutshell
a personal historian is someone who
assists people and documenting their
life stories whether that be through
organizing family photographs leading
storytelling groups or helping them
right there autobiographies they can
also do genealogy archival work research
and anything else a historian employed
by a museum or university might do but
they don't do their work a big project
for major figures they do it on everyday
people like you would need now that
doesn't really explain how I help my
clients or try to help my clients what I
mean to say is I try to treat every
client with whom I interact like I am
documenting their life story for
posterity even if i'm not actually
writing it down because the way I see it
their story is becoming a part of my
story and vice versa the way I interact
with them and the way I elicit their
stories either allows their story to
grow and become more complex
developed or depending on my manner I
can stunt its growth if I listen to
someone it gives them power but I can't
give them power if I don't have any of
my own the goal of this presentation is
to convince you that you do have some
power even in an agency that leaves you
feeling desperate disenfranchised and
alone more power than you imagine and
you can use that power and give some to
your clients this is something I've
learned this year at my own unhappy
field placement personal history work
involves giving power to the clients by
observing and preserving the past and
allowing them to reframe their narrative
in a new way it can lead to wisdom and
growth instead of just repeating the
same old story to another nameless face
who doesn't really care who is just
writing the story down for the clients
chart I try to be as engaged and present
and mindful as possible despite
circumstances that inhibit this I try to
give them power in the therapeutic
relationship that they won't otherwise
get I won't same perfect at applying
this not at all but this is what I
aspire to do so I have isolated three
concrete skills that if you take just
one or two of them away you know I hope
it will help your own personal practice
so number one as you've probably heard
before history is written by the victors
so by treating your clients story with
the respect and dignity that that of a
historian documenting an important
person or experience you can make the
client feel like they can impact the
future if they feel that they have
changed history that gives them power to
impact the future and that means they
can make positive change for themselves
in their community they don't need to be
President to do good work good work in
the world number two don't ask so many
questions full disclosure this is a
skill I attribute to doctors weapons
motivational interviewing class so
please go to the seminar today on
motivational interviewing it is well
worth it and I highly recommend it so
basically when you asked question after
question after question after question
of a client your clients become fatigued
and then makes it more likely that they
won't come back so what can you do
instead reflect on what they said this
doesn't mean yeah uh-huh yeah yeah I see
don't be afraid to go ahead and say in
its home that is confidence so that
makes me feel paralyzed or so that means
you feel frustrated keep keep that
questioning after tone out of your voice
that tone were you like so that makes
you frustrated yeah yeah you want to
keep that out of your voice because it
it diminishes your own power and
prevents the client from feeling more
powerful as well so let the client
breathe remember you are documenting and
witnessing and helping them process
their own experiences you are not
interrogating them leave that to the
other systems number three at risk of
sounding like I'm contradicting myself
be curious personal history people who
practice personal history want to know
more and find ways to accomplish that
without making their clients defensive
so when you hear something that doesn't
make sense call the client out on it in
a nice social work away of course um so
I hear you are wanting to be a better
better father to your son but I also see
that you're spending a lot of time out
drinking with your friends so I'm
confused can you explain to me how that
works out for you that's an example that
doctors weapon used in class and he
called it the Colombo approach it's
fantastic so please go to the seminar
it's really great um so basically those
are my tips treat your client as an
agent who can change history don't
interrogate your client and be curious
now before I part i have a few quotes
from personal historians that are useful
two outs of social workers number one
never doubt that you can change history
you already have Marge Piercy number two
the past actually happened but history
is only what someone wrote down a
Whitney Brown and number three as social
workers we can convert experience into
wisdom and growth Susan wittig Albert
one last observation I would like to
make I mean I started talking off I
started off talking about limb is so I
just want to point out that Victor Hugo
who wrote the book that the musical and
the movie are based off of was a
historian if you've ever read this book
you would also discover that about
there's about a hundred pages dedicated
to the history of the Battle of Waterloo
and how it matters for a couple of
characters and he also spent almost the
same number of pages writing about the
history of the Paris sewer system but he
spends most of his seven hundred page
book which I read writing about the
people in a biographical way and it's
fascinating because he spends a lot of
time honoring those who are actually not
important people in power he spends most
of the book writing about the
disempowered who are overlooked by the
history books people who we call the
mentally ill the physically ill the
impoverished the homeless and most of
all he highlights the difficulties of
incarcerated people reintegrating into
society like Jean Valjean we may think
of victor hugo is just a writer of
fiction but ultimately he is a historian
we too can be historians in our line of
work raising our clients by up by
treating their stories as valuable and
important even if we're not writing them
down a personal historian approach
involves being mindful being empathetic
being socially conscious a personal
historian approach means that we can
inspire change in those disempowered
people who are labeled by these systems
with numbers allowing the 2460 ones to
flower to Jean Valjean